Okay, we're
back. Weird internet
outage. Anyways, back for uh whatever 15
20 minutes before
meeting. That was
weird. Haven't had it uh be spotty here,
man.
multinnomial. Yes, this is this gives
you
multinnomial
Um so multinnomial works when you do not
give it probabilities
evidently what does multinnomial expect
you to give
it input
Some
samples do not need to sum to one but
must be non- negative finite and have a
nonzero
sum. So if you pass this thing in it
dies I
My adviser says he's enjoying spectating
your Pokemon tweet
replies. I don't know what it is, man.
You poke a little bit of fun at Google
cuz like, you know, with all their
resources or whatever, they're like,
"Oh, we're announcing we've beaten
Pokemon." It's like, "All right, we did
it a couple months ago on a GPU." And
everybody loses their
[ __ ] including Yap, including Yap
Scene.
I don't think these pe people hate RL.
These people just don't have opinions,
right? They're just like doing the
latest thing and they're very defensive
of their doing of the latest
thing. All right, whatever.
Ah, so this is a
thing. Cannot sample without
replacement.
How am I using
this probs and
n
multinnomial? Oh no, I see how this
works, right? Yeah, this is fine.
It probably doesn't need to be sampled
with a
replacement. No, they're way too mad. I
don't freaking Are they? I mean, there
hasn't been that much. Unless I've
missed quote
tweets. There really hasn't been that
much. Did you see the maze solver we put
out, by the way? It's a pretty damn good
solver. Look at
this. That is RL trained in 90
seconds. It like actually backtracks
like pretty well at a high level. Like
look, it actually solves this.
That's the type of thing you'd want for
net hack, right? Doesn't just get stuck
in a corner somewhere.
Like this in particular, like this
backtracking here is pretty impressive.
Yeah, I know it's only a tiny part of
the difficulty, but like it's the purest
example of like a [ __ ] exploration
problem that's really hard to learn
tabularasa, right? And we solve
that. It's pretty
good. I didn't even redo the hyper pram
sweep, man. I just ran it with like the
latest advantage filtering and stuff.
Sample factory
baseline. See, that was your mistake.
You should have gotten the puffer
baseline working
There's so many implementation
details. What do you mean porting it for
a you don't have to you don't have to
port any of it. You just need the you
just need the environment and the
policy and then just run our defaults
and it'll do better.
Like that's the idea. The goal is not
that we do exactly what whatever whoever
else does. The goal is that you just you
take your thing, you run it on puffer,
maybe you do a sweep, and we just
win like across the board. And it's
pretty well there. Like we're solving a
ton of different problems at this point.
explode? If you give this thing ins, it
explodes, right?
I don't think it'll work without their
net hack specific
hacks. I
mean, we do have a dramatically better
trainer and algorithm and tooling. Like,
we've got some pretty darn good stuff at
this point. Also, it's a heck of a lot
easier to use.
and to like hack on new stuff
with. You just need to have the N run
nice and fast for me. If you get the M
to run nice and fast, we can probably
just We're not going to just full solve
net hack, right? That's AI complete. But
I think we'll do pretty damn well.
Well, but like you can use that version
of the codebase with puffer, right? We
just have like a gymlike interface or a
gym ve like interface. Your
Do they have Okay, I'm thinking the one
thing with Sample Factory that might
still be better, I think you would want
to have
a C or C++ multi-threading based uh
vecend back end
ideally. So, if you had one of those,
you could just plug it into Puffer like
because you could just match the VEC
interface to it. Um, and then you could
still use our trainer and our sweeps and
stuff and our algorithm and we you'd
still
win. Oh, wait. Is it
not I forget if it's not process safe or
not thread safe? Net hack. You'd have to
check on
that. I actually I can't think of
why because of the
globals. Maybe it isn't thread safe. I
don't know.
I will spend at least three days
seriously trying to make a a net hack
based on work and puffer. I just think
it'll be hard. Okay, I'm very happy with
that and I will very well help you when
you want uh when you want to see that
happen. Net hack isn't thread safe and
but NLE
is
interesting. I mean, you can always just
run like the 16 processes or whatever uh
with Puffer, but you're just you're
limited to batch size 16, which
sucks. They make a copy of DL for each
instance,
huh? Interesting.
I mean, so
like does that mean that you can run
them on the same process or
No, can you like load that multiple
times and run them on the same process
or is that still messed up? I actually
don't know how that
works. Look, if you have unique state
and you can load me a thousand copies of
Net Hack, I think we insta win.
If you can do like a thousand copies of
Net Hack or like let's say 1024 and we
split them on 16 workers, right? And we
just alternate back and forth batches of
512. We run like uh you know say 36
million some like we run like some
reasonably sized model on
that. We'll even have DDP working with
that. So we can even run distributed.
Let's say we did like single node. Well,
single node distributed doesn't really
help you because you're going to be uh
you're going to be CPU bound. Um, but
like even if we just ran on like one
good box, let's say we got like a one or
two GPU box with a Thread Ripper on it,
like a 64 uh CPU Thread Ripper, like we
should probably just
win. They can run hundreds on 10 CPUs.
Yeah, but if they're opening just a
separate process per M is lame, right?
And also Puffer Libs Vec doesn't like it
when you do
that. Like I could make a hacked version
of it that wouldn't be as bad for that,
but it's just way better if you cannot
have them be single like for process.
I will actually help you with that
though if you if you seriously want to
do net hack stuff and like we'll put in
time then I will also put in some time
to like make that work
well and like in your assessment like
was the rapper done competently?
man. Yeah. So, I think that that would
be usually just assuming that out that
researchers did any low-level thing that
they touched wrong is a good
assumption. I can look at it with
you. You know, low-level gamedev is a
lot of fun and it makes RL go very fast.
I'm surprised you haven't jumped onto
this boat yet. I mean, it's like it's
gamedev. It's RL. It doesn't
[Laughter]
suck. That seems like it would be right
up your
alley. And you no longer have the I have
to graduate excuse either.
Like heck, if you want uh if you want to
just jam some RL for a bit and you just
want like a stipen to do whatever until
you find something, I'm happy to do
that. Come on, slaughtered for just
doing whatever I want.
Awesome. That'll be cool.
I mean, at this point, like, nothing
else is being really maintained anymore
and like actively improved. So, it seems
kind of weird to like do it on something
that isn't Puffer. Like, there are
literally no other RL libraries that are
like actively being developed to this
extent. Like, we're kind of just doing
the
thing. You think I got a meeting in
five?
Wait, let's see. Net hack sample factory
is being used by the only team working
at Net Hack. I
see that's why the baseline's two times
better than the moon one.
H. It's probably a pretty small team
though, right? Is this a thing where
like if I made a a ridiculously better
puffer baseline, they would they like
there's no way Meta would want a puffer
contract for that, right?
impossible. Wouldn't want to onboard
onto something. What if the onboarding
is run the script? You want to see
something beautiful? Look what I did.
Look what I Look what I managed to do.
All
right. This is the transcript of Puffer.
It is less than a thousand lines of real
code.
Less than a thousand lines of real code
here. And this is the full transcript,
including the old demo
file. Maybe 10 people and some
interns. Who would win? 10 people and
some interns or one
puffer? I think we answered that
question with the Google stuff the other
day, right?
puffer. What is this? This is ultra high
performance reinforcement learning dev.
We do research. We build game
environments. We build other types of
environments. It's all open source. It's
all free and uh we've got a bunch of
contributors working on all sorts of
interesting projects in this
space. Of course, it's coding. It's
always
coding. I do have to run in a minute
though because uh I think I'm going to
have a meeting whenever this guy
messages me, but I will be back
for probably a couple hours before
dinner and a couple hours after as well.
So, this pretty much worked instantly on
sample
factory. Uh, technically it shouldn't be
that
hard.
Wait, it wouldn't be that
hard. Like, our multiprocessing setup is
generally way less jank than uh like the
gymnasium or whatever ve stuff.
I mean we also we are doing curriculum
learning stuff in puffer now right with
Aaron's
work I'm making I'm not currently making
a game I've made no several and other
contributors have made other ones at the
moment I am currently
Cleaning up all this code for our next
release.
only two here for
chat. I mean it's a small stream. It's
anywhere from 0 to 10 depending
We're getting more on Twitch. It depends
on the day, honestly. Oh, six on Twitch.
Hello. Welcome,
folks. Yeah. So for new pe new new uh
people here this is this is pufferlib.
This is what I work on full-time. Um it
is very easy to use and very high
performance reinforcement learning. So
like this breakout agent trains in less
than a minute on just your local GPU. We
have fancier stuff as well like this
mini like big world. Lots of
agents items equipment weapons a market.
And you can play them all on this
website too.
But yeah, this is an open source
project. So if we have any more
technical folks around here, you do not
need RL experience. Some of our top
contributors came in with zero RL
experience
um and are now like contributing tons of
cools to uh to the project. Great way to
learn AI and
RL. The thing that's most helpful is
having a little bit of low-level
programming
experience. We write all these in C. It
is very simple C like first year
undergrad level C very simple. Um but
yeah we try to really make like all this
complicated stuff pretty easy to work
with.
This is research is what it is. This is
not just like developing a game. Like we
develop games as part of
research. No, I'm a PhD in reinforcement
learning. I've worked on this stuff for
many years. I'm now trying to make it
faster, better, more stable. uh useful
for hobbyists, people just having fun
training RL on stuff, but also for like
legitimate academic research and for
industry problems as
well. So that's kind of how it works
around here.
not import exceptions. Yeah, we have to
refactor a whole bunch of stuff Now,
I don't know why I made all these little
tiny files in the first place.
Frankly, this is just going to be so
much easier.
When you get back from meeting, do you
want to go over a problem of having with
action shape errors? Absolutely. I
didn't know that you were
here. I can look at stuff now. I don't
like this guy. Of course, as soon as I
start looking at your thing, I'm sure
he's going to message me. But for all I
know, he might not show up. He might do
whatever. He said whenever he finishes
his previous meeting, but that was
supposed to be 7 minutes
ago. I don't have a clean commit state
though at the moment. So maybe let me
finish this refactor and if he hasn't
pinged me by then then I'll do
it. What's going on? This is
reinforcement learning dev. Uh I build
puffer lib. All the stuff's at
puffer.ai. We've got demos. You can play
them here. You can see RL agents trained
in your
browser. And uh I stream all my dev on
this project. So ultra high performance,
simple to use, reinforcement learning,
research, algorithms, infrastructure,
all that. All open source and uh we're
always looking for new
contributors. Many of our best ones came
in with zero RL
experience. Oh, you know, I wonder if
I'm getting uh new viewers from the the
Yaps the Yakian
thing. That'd be funny.
The rage bait might It wasn't even a
rage bait is the thing. I was just like
poking a little bit of fun at at Google
like it's cuz kind of lighthearted. just
like ah well you know we did that two
months ago with like one
GPU bots had me
rolling. I mean it like I don't know
people made a the Gemini and whatever
people got kind of buttth hurt over it.
It was like it was like a little joke
because it's like yeah obviously they're
not the same thing but it's still it was
kind of funny the way they posted it
where they're like ah yes artificial
Pokemon intelligence and stuff. So, all
right, congrats on second place. We did
it a couple months ago with uh with
Puffer Lib on one GPU with Tabularasa
RL,
right? What's the best research for
students who are interested in RL? I
love your PhD presentation. Hey, thanks.
Uh right here, right here for uh if
you're getting into RL, like this is the
place. We've got a quick start guide
right here. This is much more
technically accessible than like even
something like spinning up. Uh it'll
link you to a singledigit number of
papers and blog posts to read that give
you most of the important stuff that's
out
there. And honestly, the best way to get
into RL is to like build an environment
like build a new problem from scratch
and then go through the process of
making RL work on it. And with Puffer
Lib you can make that process very very
fast. So you can train it a million
steps per second. So that takes you like
two days instead of two months and you
can get help the whole way through
because we are always looking for like
if you're looking to get into RL frankly
this is like we try to make this a place
where as long as you want to open source
stuff we help stuff out it helps grow
the project and all the new Ms that
people build in the process of this
become essentially tests for all the
algorithms that we build. Uh so it also
helps advance the research as well.
What? I don't know what you're referring
to
there. Oh, is that my iceberg video?
That's a fun overview. It's mostly still
all relevant as well.
I hope people watch that thing. I put a
lot of work into that. That was how I
decided, okay, I'm not going to be
making YouTube videos. Um, it's just not
worth it. I I should be spending my time
actually doing research and just do all
this stuff live.
right you have a channel on YouTube.
Yep. Um, I I'm here YouTube, which it
just streams to all the platforms and
then all the VODs just go to
YouTube. They're not edited or anything
and they get cut up every time, you
know, there's an internet outage or I
have to like go do a thing or whatever,
but you can technically you have all the
the logs up there.
This has got to be like some weird
import order thing,
lib. It's probably like imports too much
stuff or something.
is It's probably from
pufferlib.pufferlib import star,
Yeah, maybe we will just leave it
like like this.
3:15 Easter. Yeah, I don't know.
I was supposed to have a meeting uh 15
minutes ago, but
iceberg vid is like a good
overview the post on that I like I
should brought up on puffer.ai as well
that blog
post I mean I made those for new people
looking to get into this
stuff most of the environments on
puffer.ai
AI.
Um, like most of those are from
contributors.
Yes. Okay, that's
clean. Now, you can argue whether I'm
making it actually better or not doing
this
stuff, but I don't know. I I like it
more this
way. And it makes it way
[Music]
easier. It cleans up the name
spaces. I should have done this a long
time ago.
Whether that's stable or not, who knows?
But this is a dev branch, so who
cares? So now we have a whole bunch of
stuff in this 450 line file instead of
having like five separate fiddly little
files.
uh in Pupper now, we've got
emulation.py, we've got a little Sython
code extensions, we've got
models, got
pufferlib.py, got a CUDA kernel, we've
got some C stuff in here. We have our
pietorch
stuff. We've got spaces. Got
sweeps. The only thing that I don't know
about is
Um, right. So, the thing I was doing
before was I was just looking for dead
code in here.
Yeah. So, this validate args, we get rid
of
args? Okay, that's actually a little
suspicious. Oh, you know what we did? We
changed it to anything in the config
instead of anything in this init. So we
simplified a little
bit. I know we use unroll nested dict a
bunch.
uh but we might have install and
import. No, we don't use this
utils and in vector but I think vector
has its own checks.
anymore. Why are you ignoring? Cuz
you're just saying random stuff in my
chat.
Uh, make zeros.
Okay. So this is I think we do use this
for tests,
right? So it would be compare space
samples I
guess. Yeah. So this is only used in
tests it looks like.
into. We should move like this
stuff. How about compare arrays? Hang
on. So, all of this stuff needs to get
moved here.
bounce. Okay, so this actually does get
used.
So, I think we just take this stuff
here and we put this into like
a
temporary. We use this in two different
places. I'll put this in test I for
now. Maybe
And I'll add a todo fix
this was in
utils
only. Okay. So then there's get dtype
bounce.
This is only used in
used. Yeah, I just like left a bunch of
garbage in here.
um we have that in in clean puffer. We
do not use this
profiler or this or this. We replace all
of this actually.
And then I believe we do use
suppress. We do use
suppress in several M's that are
annoying. Okay. Order dict doesn't get
used.
Null context doesn't get used. Time
doesn't get used.
OS OS gets used.
Pickle subprocess
direct. Yeah, we use these redirects
still ring io. We use
this
organized. 510
lines. Not bad.
I'm surprised you're using grap instead
of something like
telescope. I just don't use that many
tools.
Like I've like never really bothered to
get into using
very many tools like at
all. I don't know. I use a pretty small
set of pretty simple things.
Cool. That now that now works. That
should be a big uh commit diff.
code size getting smaller is
good. So, aside from this, I think we
only
have we only have uh clean puffl, right?
which is only like another
thousand. Oh, and this is also not the
um the full line count, right? This
includes like whites space.
So once that gets moved
in, I mean 4,000 linesish for all the
puffer pythons pretty
solid. I think it can even get smaller
than this if we like work on some
things. And then obviously the uh most
of the expansion is in C.
And really if you think about it
like the actual stack that we use is
probably half of this and the rest is
like for emulation for stuff like
Atari. There's probably stuff in PyTorch
we can delete as well. But this is I
mean this is like a pretty darn
Let's um let's start taking a look at
your
stuff. Plasma, let's start taking a look
at your uh your code here cuz I don't
know where these guys
are. I don't know. This is like the
second or third time they've done this.
Well,
Perfect. I've been waiting for this one
for a
while. I've actually I really wanted
this amp to play around
Is this um PR review or is there are
there issues that need to be
fixed? Okay, so this is the second time
now I've seen this. Why Why does
everybody have
these? Like did you get these from
captain or from
uh these came from somewhere, right? Oh,
from Bet. Yeah, this is from Damn it.
Yeah, Bet didn't It's a lot easier than
this. Um yeah, Bet didn't understand the
way that we were doing stuff with our
VEC API when he did this. I can show you
how that works.
Yeah, this is about what it should look
like. Something like this. I would
expect to see like a numbum agents param
in here or something if it's not just
hardcoded. Oh, it's hardcoded. Okay.
Well, it's hardcoded
here. Huh.
There probably should be a agents
here, but you want me to do uh leave
comments on this so it's easier for you
to track
stuff. Just trying to get everything
working. Okay, then let's let's actually
we we can do even uh I'm not looking for
a review as of yet. Okay. So, what what
is it that you'd like me to look at
then? Like what is the thing that
doesn't
work? Action shape bug. Gotcha. Gotcha.
Okay. I have multiple contributors and I
I didn't remember whether it was you who
had the action bug. Okay, cool.
weird. All right, but this is
built. Um, what was it?
branch. Probably in a branch,
right? Create voids.
build? You wanna just push to your Yeah,
just push to your thing and I'll pull
Just push to that branch and I'll pull
this real
It's like random stuff and then people
shilling a crypto
scam. That's funny.
Oh yeah, in the meantime we can check.
Um Oh, this is still crashing,
right? Wait, hang
on. Didn't we start another sweep? What
happened?
Oh, wait. The This is Pong. Yeah, we
started a Pong sweep. That must have
crashed. That's
annoying. I thought that that would have
fixed
loss binary. Search
for
multinnomial. So it is screwing up in
the multinnomial kernel.
weird.
Enduro, you mean voids, right?
Dude, I love
this. This is so
good. Oh man, I wanted one of these for
so long.
And it's funny because like I
technically built something that you
could sort of argue would work in uh in
the grid system, but this is going to be
like such an easier and cleaner way of
doing
it. Doing
something
[Music]
hovers. That's awesome.
not import binding. So I I have to
compile this, right?
Uh, you did not add a binding here
yet. Oh, how is this supposed to train
if there's no
binding? Unless I'm wrong. Is there like
voids? Yeah, there's no voids in here,
man. Wait, how is this supposed to train
if there's no binding for
It makes
virtual. Well, I'm I should get UV
because it's fast. We don't have virtual
M's. You see, like we're in containers.
So, like if you're stacking virtual M's
inside of containers, it's like you've
put an MV in like I don't know. That's
that's got to be illegal or something,
right? Like putting a bag of holding in
a portable hole.
Yeah, it's helpful if you're not in a
container, but we like our
containers. Even for local dev, I have
container like because I have an
identical setup then right here and on
the
cluster. It's like it's just it helps so
much to just have the full
container. That is something I am
working on
Jason. I am working on that. But that's
only in
dev. That is only in the dev branch.
Uh there is technically you do kind of
need CUDA with the new stuff plasma.
There's um because we ship CUDA kernels
and uh you need like a graceful CPU
fallback. So that is something that I am
working on. There will be a graceful
fallback. I already figured out how to
do it. I just have to adjust some stuff
in the setup.py
still. It took like four hours. It was
not fun.
There's one
M. No, hold on. Let me see what you did.
M some
voids. So, this supposed to be one M and
one void, except that the defaults will
spawn two M's. So, it is two M's with
one void each, I
The single the single space is for a
single
agent. Each board is an agent.
Now, this is going to take absolutely
forever because
um well, you have
one environment being passed.
three. Yeah. So, you set this to -3 to 3
and the policy is not doing anything to
clip this. So, you didn't even get to
this error, I assume, here. Um, but this
would be you set it to like negative in
inf or your policy has to clip it
somehow. So, we're going to set
Oops. Okay. So, you clip it, but you
clip it to the action space. So, this is
too late cuz the check has already
occurred. You'd want to do something
like this.
I mean to be fair this is something that
I could improve on in the continuous
API. Let me let me see about
right? Those are just array lib leaks.
Yeah. Fine. Uh, float
logging. Is this Syon or is this um
bindings?
Cool. So when does this termination get
called? Current void reward less
than.99F.
So this is if they get to the edge of
the
screen. Is it possible for them to get
this far? Cuz like don't they get cut
off? Cuz like the puffer has some width
to
it. Yeah. So the puffer is like isn't it
going to get cut off way before.99?
Rewards are cumulative.
That's
sure current. This is current void
reward. And then this is set with a hard
equal. Hey bro, what are you doing? I'm
currently helping Plasma here debug this
awesome new
environment in which there are lots of
puffer fish swimming around.
We're going to get reinforcement
learning working on
this. We're going to get this thing
debugged. Can we move and just try
something real
quick? Make sure it's not a thing that I
could like easily guess. Oh, also you
have to uh manually for now purge old
builds until I figure out a way to clean
this
this. That is a new annoying quirk. I
will figure out how to fix that.
Okay. So, the thing I suggested was
completely
wrong. A video for
you and make videos teaching people
RL. Well, I made a couple of them. The
thesis defense did really well. The one
after didn't. So, I just figured um
mostly I just stream all the dev live
now and I answer stuff while I'm working
on things. It takes a long time to make
videos and really the main objective
here is to push RL forward. I can't be
doing research if I'm making videos all
day.
Current void reward
is reward
minus. This is a normalized thing.
All right. These rewards seem completely
wrong to me,
right? Like it's mostly getting a ton of
reward.
I've not
seen there's a small
negative. Junior CS student in Egypt. I
also built my own deep learning
framework. Give you GitHub to look at. I
love
research. Like um you built like your
own autograd type
thing. That's a common exercise we do.
Uh well it depends how much you go into
it right like uh CS231N is a course I
recommend everyone they have you do
something similar we have um a
inferenceon one in pure C and puffer
liib as
well I don't know if the right thing to
do is you get an intern as a research
student typically you just have to like
meet and talk with professors for the
most part
Um it's very difficult to get a research
internship uh as an undergraduate at
like a a big lab or somewhere. You can
get applied stuff, not really research
stuff unless you're like you have uh
some solid publication history and then
yes, you can potentially do
that. But best bet is to do like uh
stuff in academic labs.
So, I don't know what this reward
function is supposed to be,
man. But, um, whatever it is currently,
maybe I can figure it
It also you don't have to make them
respawn ever, right? The the actual ones
in voids don't ever respawn. I think you
were just looking for a way to get logs
in, weren't you?
You can get actions into it with eval no
problem either
Um, I mean, yeah, like depending on the
type of thing, it can either
be it's like anything from a basic
exercise up to you built PyTorch,
I mean, what what is your goal though in
um like what's your goal in showing me
this? Like I can technically review
whatever ML stuff. Yeah. But we mainly
do uh reinforcement learning and
reinforcement learning adjacent things
here.
just make
feedback. I mean, I can look at stuff
briefly if you link it. Sure. I am
trying to figure out what's going on
with the sound right now,
though. I also know where this guy is.
He said at 3:15 and he just disappeared.
Still
nothing. This is starting to get a
little spooky. Like
why? It shouldn't even matter if it's
incorrect anymore, man. It should still
just work.
So this is obviously not returning
anything at
Okay. So this is adding logs
right. Add log is getting called
Have you made any
publications? Well, yes, of course.
Don't get a PhD without doing
that. I don't know when is the right
time to start doing a paper or
something. It depends on your plans. If
you want to go to grad school and do
stuff, then yes, you need publications.
Um, if you're doing stuff in industry,
they help, but depending on the role,
you may or may not need
them. Uh, my
first my first publication was uh my
sophomore year of undergrad after I'd
been doing research for
about I don't know close to a
year. So, I' I'd done research before
then as well, just it wasn't very good.
But my first like decent piece of
research, I'd
enough. Okay. So, you have this binding
thing.
Where do you work and what was your
first paper about? I work on Puffer
full-time. This is my job. Um, it's all
free and open source, but we do have a
few companies that pay us for priority
service, our eyes on their problems,
extended support, running our stuff
early on their on their problems,
generally helping with that
side. Uh, my first paper was in a
completely different area. It was about
language modeling. You can read it here.
It's It's not amazing. It was pretty
decent for me being like 18 or 19 at the
time, I think. But where is it?
Recurrent highway hyper
networks. This would not be publishable
nowadays. Uh the bar is higher now. But
also you have to realize that the tools
that we had back then were nowhere near
as good as what we have now. So, this
was like super early, super jank PyTorch
beta on like a jank like Franken desktop
that I rigged
up.
log. Welcome YouTube folks.
This is currently debugging a
contributor's
environment. Let's fix the ISO on this
camera as
well.
Better upcoming contributor. Fair
enough. Got to actually submit the
voids. Have it working.
It gets cleared on reset,
right? When does this get called?
Never. Do I do need to solve a problem
in the paper? Can I propose an
idea? Oh, man. If that's like the level
that you're asking about, like, yeah,
there's going to be some work to do for
sure. Um, the way that you get started
in research is that you pick an area
that interests you for which you have at
least something that reasonably
approaches the technical background to
be able to at least teach yourself some
stuff in. So like if you know absolutely
no math, don't pick a math heavy area of
research, right? If you know absolutely
no programming or no like low-level
programming, probably don't pick systems
research, right? You pick an area of
research that you're interested in where
you have at least something that is a
reasonably close to the prerequisites to
be able to understand what's going on.
Uh you start looking for papers in that
space that are interesting. At first,
you're not really going to know which
ones are useful or important. You can
join Discords. You can like check on X.
You can like try to find people like
recommend you stuff to read. There are
lots of guides on like you know papers
to read if you're like want to learn X
you know you read those papers you get a
sense of the structure of a research
paper you get a sense of how science is
done you get a sense of the types of
things uh that papers are like the scope
of a paper and like what a paper is
looking to do like what is the type of
contribution that is valued and then
once you've read enough papers you maybe
you get a new idea or something like oh
you know I could do something like this
but maybe I do it in like this way
instead and we see what happens.
Ideally, you pick something where it's
not ridiculously difficult to implement
your idea. Um, then you go and you
implement it, you test it, you run the
comparison, and if it does better, then
you write it up as a paper. You write
up, you know, the background on the
method that you're approaching, how you
like thought about how to make an
improvement. You detail the experiments
that you did. And that is most of a
paper. And yeah, that is like kind of
the first basic paper that you do. Now
later on you'll get ideas that are not
just one step removed from something
existing, right? You'll get like
completely new ideas when you are more
experienced. Uh and then that is a
little bit harder to frame stuff in. But
usually you start with trying to do
something on top of something that
already
exists. You do not go implement every
single paper. You go implement a few of
the easier to implement papers.
Ideally like when I started I
implemented I don't know some
variational autoenccoders I did some
like basic language modeling stuff right
I maybe did some like basic vision stuff
but I didn't like go implement anything
that's thousands of lines of Good.
something. Like I do not suggest, oh,
first paper, time to reimplement llama
from scratch. Like you're not going to
have a fun
time, mixture of experts. You want to
see some crazy stuff? This was the
second paper that I tried to
do. All right. This was the second
freaking paper I tried to do. This is
like a dynamically assembled
architecture. Where's the figure? Yeah.
So, this is a dynamically assembled
architecture. So where each problem
instance assembles a different graph and
then we came up with this like
topological sort thing to like group
nodes based on what nodes were being
used often so that it run at a half
decent speed. This was a nightmare.
Don't do this. You will not have any
fun. Of course, I'm shouldn't be one to
talk about fun because I like started on
neural MMO and then banged my head
against it for six years until I got
somewhere. All right, man. What did you
do? Why is this thing not
logging? Like, it ought to log
something, you would think.
anything?
Like I'm not seeing it.
You have a vex
step that looks
it. I implemented batchorm also dynamic
computation graphs also hard attention
like I'm trying yeah the backwards
password for batch norm is a pain in the
assic I'm trying man like what are you
trying to do building this thing though
right
like I built a I built like a mini pie
torch is a cool project it's not a
research paper
right it's a good way to learn
stuff. In fact, it's like one of the
best ways to learn the nuts and
bolts. Like, if you know how those
networks work, you should be able to
read some papers, right? And like get a
sense of how they're structured, what
they're trying to do.
Is this step function just getting not
like getting called at all?
step should uh appear through. Print
should definitely appear here,
right? Oh, you know what? I bet you did.
Hang
on. Let me
see. That
is 256. You see this a whole bunch of
times. You know what I bet you
did? I bet that you I bet we can figure
out exactly what you
did. Oh, and this is one of the cool
things, by the way.
Like, you want to see something cool
here? Let me show you how you would have
fixed this yourself. Um, because I think
we're going to find your bug right
here. Right there.
71 PDB- args boom breaker lib ocean
voids
voids.h 171 start of this
loop run you can step and see with pdb
yep that's one of the main advantages of
the new API over Syon isn't that cool
uh except
Oh, hold on. That's just my OS.
I think it's just silly thing. Don't
worry about it. Yeah, there we
go. Uh, now I do have to set the one
other thing I forgot to do. We have to
set vec to
serial so we can debug in one process.
not? Oh, cuz I I'm on the wrong line.
Hang on.
Okay. Okay. So, there you go. This is
how you would have fixed your problem.
I'm going to show you. Let's I'm going
to look very stupid if I'm wrong about
what this bug is, but look. So, you
would put some break point in here so
you can see what the heck is going on,
right? Why aren't we getting to your
code?
Um, there you
go. That's why we're not getting to your
code. So, I've I can see exactly because
and I see exactly why this happened.
It's cuz you initialized it in the C. C
file and you didn't initialize it from
Python.
You didn't initialize it anywhere. You
see?
So, I guessed your bug and then I showed
you how you would confirm that even if
you didn't happen to guess your
bug. So, you have your numboids right
here.
Mids. This is the thing that was
suspicious to me, right?
still
zero. So,
um, binding file not getting recompiled
or some weird thing.
Good
call. Uh, I know I did remove the
binding file.
go. Beckonet requires
Six
on. I think you missed something. Hang
on.
[Music]
Ocean Beck in
NIT. What is it? It
is num m. No, num m is
uh in arcs.
You missed the seed. So that's why it
worked. Otherwise, it would have given
you a nice error
message. But uh you missed the
seed. Device side assert trigger. Really
immediately.
Well, that's a MI
issue. Oh, kind of. It probably means
your hyper pram suck if it's failing
that quickly.
Let's just do
4096 one void
each. 32
voids. What's
Holy
cannot
not. I
need this. No, agent's wrong.
Did I rename it to like agent or
something? I think I used this notation
from petting zoo though. I think that's
why I used this.
Oh, you know what this is? This is
numbum m. Hang on. This is numbum m. Uh,
does this beckonet not do
technically. I know I could be wrong. I
don't
know. Ah, because numbum agents is
numboids now.
too. You do not have this in the step
function.
ought to be something
now. Did I accidentally make a massive
number of M's or something? I don't
think so.
What do you think of a new style of RL?
Maybe instead of a neural network, you
could evolve a code
base using
LMS. Uh, that's like Voyager style
stuff. Yeah, that paper is mostly a
sham. and uh LM still absolutely suck at
coding. Give it a couple of generations
and maybe but even then like scripting
just doesn't work for all problems. Like
um it's good in some cases and bad in
others. You're still going to want
action
here. That's a step up. It is actually
calling your log function.
Yes, you need different like
it's like go ahead and script me a Dota
bot that beats Open AI5, right? Like
how? It's hard.
Num
M's not get
set. Surely this gets set,
right? Yeah, this gets set right here.
I can imagine Dota being
doable if you have entity
base observation. You could maybe evolve
an enormous
codebase. It would be really freaking
hard. You know what? Actually, I have an
example for you. Tesla tried really hard
to do this. uh they wrote 300,000 lines
of C++ and then replaced it with a
neural network. So there you
go. So that is and that is written by
programmers that are much better at
least you would hope many of them are uh
much better than current LLMs which are
awful.
maybe driven by the observation space
that is with them having classifiers and
stuff for object
recognition. Still end up having 300,000
lines of
C++. It's very hard to script
everything. And then there are places
where it's actually way easier to script
things, right?
I'm going to go put a breakpoint in
inside the freaking Python binding
itself because I don't know how this has
managed to be a thing. This is
ludicrous.
M's. There's your N. It is voids.
float. You have float float
float. This is not an int. This is a
float.
I should probably make it so that this
doesn't
explode. Sure.
You hear me? Yep. How's it going?
Good. Right. We're making progress on
this thing.
I kind of I mean we got first we tr I
tried u making the Syon bindings
um I couldn't pass like actions and
observations to it like I I the way you
guys were doing it. So uh it just told
me do the new Cbinding thing. So that's
kind of what I'm
doing. Right. I think I got the audio
balanced now.
had to mite down the desktop audio a
little bit.
Um, yeah. So, this is actually this is
useful as well because I get to see
where it is like where you can possibly
screw up stuff. Mhm.
Hey, B.
Hello, B. Ah, there we go. Easy easy
fix.
Nice. So, what was the issue? Uh, yeah.
You know, I probably should make it work
if you screw that up. Oh, the float the
float thing. Yeah, you you can probably
check for that maybe.
Yeah. Um like air out like that should
be float. Well, it's tough cuz then you
have to do it dynamically like you can't
dynamically inspect types. It's C,
right?
Where's uh print fat?
Where the heck am I printing log from?
[Music]
Where uh
Python? I think I was
maybe it's
uh uh just grap the codebase. I don't
know. Log is everywhere.
I guess I can grab from here. I don't
know. Oh yeah.
orh as well, not just pi. Why is this
thing Oh, cuz I'm not in the directory.
Yeah.
On a call right now. Is it fixed? We're
fixing it.
We're working on it. Trace log. No, it's
different. Uh,
there's just a just a print f or a print
or there's something. Yeah. Um,
binding. Oh, it's the binding file.
Yeah, that might be a binding.h. Yep.
Bad.
Or binding C.
Got
it.
Oh, wow.
Okay, we are getting stats.
Yep. They're not good stats, but they
are stats. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Better than
nothing.
So then you have to do some reward
stuff. Yep. Uh yeah, I know. I know
exactly why the rewards I think I know
why the rewards are being dumb there. Um
Mhm. Well, yeah. Continuous rewards are
kind of hard. Like discrete rewards for
events are a lot easier. I guess it has
to be continuous for voids, but yeah,
you'll get to play with this. Yeah, cuz
I Yeah, I have to basically I get the
rewards from the um how similar the
average vector is like the you know like
the vector you calculate from the uh
rules in Boyds how similar it is to the
one that the um policy gave you.
How would you like me to get these to
you? I can zip these to you and drop
them in Discord. You can give me um push
access or what would you like? What's
the easiest? Yeah, I mean you can just
push them and I think you have access.
You own the repo. Uh I don't own your
fork.
Ah, how can I give you push
in the settings of the fork itself or
Oh, okay. I see what you mean. Uh
yeah,
settings. Give me a second. I got to use
a pass key. Yep. I will be right back
while you do that. All right. Um
Permission denied.
Ah, yeah. It looks like
So, are you Yeah, I gave it to Jay
Suarez like the 4341
5341.
Yeah, I'm waiting uh for a response, but
from what I see from your blast commits,
you're using like an account that
doesn't exist or something.
Like, uh I know. Uh let me show you
exactly what I'm talking about.
Sometimes GitHub does that. If it's it's
this this right
here. Let me see what you're showing me.
Like this is your account. Like this is
your actual account, but for some reason
you're committing stuff with
uh
huh? This is like your actual account
and you're committing stuff with I guess
a non-existent one for some reason here,
you know? Like I can Yeah.
Click on any of those. Yeah. You can't
like like let's say look at let's look
at the commit for example. The hell um
yeah it just I don't have anything that
should do that. It just ah yeah saying
his name sometimes and it's saying his
account name other times. It's probably
just inconsistent.
Yeah. You have um you're like you know
how you should be listed on I should
definitely just be listed like if you
gave perms to that account it should
work. I uh well I think you need to like
accept it says waiting like pending
invite. Why the heck do you need
I don't know. Is it just an email or
whatever?
Um I think it's in your
No, I think it should be in your uh
notification. Maybe not. Oh, yay. I have
pending dumbbell quotes.
Sounds good.
I buy myself a nice set of
ankos. Oh, are those adjustable or
stand? No, full set of fixed dumbbells.
Wow. Be nice. Fancy. There you go. Yeah,
we're doing 15 pairs. Five to 50 is in a
5 pound increment. And then 60 to 100 in
10 pound increments. Okay. Jesus Christ.
Okay. I'm not I'm guessing you have like
like you have adjustable bench and
everything. I mean, you can literally
see it in the background, right? Uh
well, your head was
Yeah, I can see it now. Yeah, the rack
sick. There's the comp bench right
there. Or not comp bench. It's not quite
comp bench. The pad's different. Um my
adjustable bench is right there. There's
the log down there. All the
surf. Yeah. I I see you got uh what's
called um string stoppers or whatever.
Like the string uh bar catchers like the
safety straps. Those are really good.
Yeah, I highly recommend those. Yeah,
for sure. If you don't want to die
squatting.
Yeah, generally preferable to not.
And I like I like training to failure
sometimes as well. So, like it's better.
What was the problem? I want I want to
know what was wrong with it. Oh, thanks.
Uh, I need to write myself a note to fix
that as
well. Uh, you pushed right. I I
pulled. See?
So, uh, there were several issues. One
was also like,
uh, you didn't push yet.
So, the two main ones that were that he
didn't he did not initialize
um the number of agents in uh in the
environment itself. Actually, there were
three main ones. one had the single
observation space he was defining for
all agents. It was the wrong shape. And
then the uh environment was
exporting or the environment wasn't
exporting logs because it had it never
got numbum agents in the initialization.
So that needed to be fixed. And then uh
additionally the log was an int. Like
the logs are intended to be all floats
right now. And we literally check
numittes. How do we become an int? like
I like how is it becoming an int because
I obviously put them all to floats when
I was when I was trying to make it work.
Uh but that didn't make it work
because they have three different bugs.
Yeah, that's probably why. Uh okay. So
observation shape was wrong. So So
plasma that that was that was one of one
of one of the I told you there's there
are many like oneline gotchas. That was
one of them I think. So yeah. Cool. I'm
I'm what I really just hope is that I
can see the actions and the observations
and like I can actually see them being
passed down to see cuz with the Syon
they weren't. Yeah. Well, you can debug
now is the nice thing. So at least like
you have break points. Exactly. Exactly.
And I saw you using GDB instead of uh
PDB as well which is I did not know GDB
can debug Python.
usually. Well, it'll it'll drop you into
the C, which is nice, right? That's uh
generally just use PTB if it's if it's
in the Python
Um it's very nice. I
know. Yeah.
Have you pushed uh those changes? Yeah,
I pushed it. Okay. This is going to be a
fun end once we have it like doing stuff
as well. Oh yeah, it's going to be a
super fun. I think for you suggestions,
don't try to make it delete agents. You
don't need to do that. You don't need to
reset the end after like end steps or
anything. Um yeah, don't delete agents.
Don't I guess I mean Yeah.
So the ends. So like when you were
saying like don't delete them, are you
just saying like don't terminate them?
Yeah, you don't need to terminate them
at all. Yeah. So just to make Yeah, just
make them like just get bad get like get
very bad reward and it's just going to
be you know Yeah. And you can just log
at fixed intervals is fine.
This maze solver really good.
Yeah, looks pretty good.
Um,
I like how we got like a few extras on
this when it was like done because of
scene. I need to It didn't do as well as
we thought so. I like it didn't do as
well as I figured cuz I guess I don't
know when you make some stupid posts,
they don't always do like ridiculously
well. I mean, this is like a ludicrously
large account to only have that many
views on something. I know. True.
I don't know. He posts constantly, so
like not all of them are crazy. Also,
notch hiring programmers for an awesome
game is like pretty cool.
Mhm.
That would be a lot of fun. Sadly, I
have to fix RL game. No vibe quarters or
new line. New line curly brace.
No. No. Putting curly braces on a new
line. Dang.
Wait, did uh I'm not seeing the
push. I'm seeing only my
commits some reason. Or did you push it
straight to my like fork? Uh there's a
new branch. Come on. We have a little
bit of a little bit of hygiene here. I
didn't just push it to your branch.
Yeah. Good.
So, what did you what did you call it?
What?
What did you name the branch you
created? Wait, you can look at all
branches if you just click on the
branches and go all view all branches.
Yeah, I tell you that many branches.
Oh, look. Boyd's fixed. I see it. Okay.
Thank you. Somebody was like typing on
his account or some [ __ ]
He DM'd me like, "Oh,
it's whatever."
That was
funny. Very
nice. That looks like a hard climb.
Why is he on a rope, though? What do you
mean? You're not going to freeze solo
that. He's not bouldering.
Is he climbing down? I never got into
climbing. I've always climbed down. I've
never not climbed down. I've never like
boulders. Yeah. Climb. Climb up. Climb
up. Well, he's probably doing like a 50
meter wall if he's using like lines. So,
rocks instead of climb them.
I actually have outside. I got a big
pile of rocks for me to lift. It's
great.
locks yesterday. It's not great. It's
awful. It's great. Lift them.
Yeah, I lift my body weight. That's
uh another thing you can do.
True. Or fun lift bar.
I have a lot of new equipment arriving
probably Friday or Monday, which is
going to be fun.
Are you going to have like uh able
machines where you can do flies or
whatever? That is arriving in three or
four weeks. And yes, we have four pieces
I believe like four commercial grade
pieces of equipment arriving. Got a dual
a dual cable tower. We've got a super
squat which is like a combo machine
squat and biking press which I've really
really wanted. Um, we got a incline
Smith machine and uh there's also this
like multi-way fit like multi-way
station because it was really cheap and
it does a ton of different things and
it's like actually not a piece of crap.
So, you're literally building puffer
fitness. No, it's puffer training
facility. It's training agents and
training me.
What's the rewards, dude? What's the
rewards? Uh, the reward for me is being
healthy and jacked. Uh, the reward for
the agent is whatever we tell them it
is.
We've also got pretty nice running
around here as well. There's like we've
got a good like um 10k of trails around
here that I can run. Oh, you have like
uh trails. Nice. So, I'm just like
keeping myself like like you know in the
local area, right? Just like right out.
I just start running and then I get back
here and it's 10k. Um and only like a
mile of it is roads which is nice.
Yeah. Yeah. I I enjoy uh running on uh
actual like gravel and stuff more than
roads like like trails. Still tough, but
uh Well, yeah. Like more like like just
earth, just like basic, you know, like
my knees were not happy with running in
Florida. Um yeah, that was not fun. So,
also I would recommend getting like a a
shoe with like a bigger uh toe box. So,
your actual I really like my uh wearing
Brooks for the last couple years for
running. I really like them. I really
like those. Ghosts. Uh Brooks. Yeah,
Brooks. Uh Ghost. Is that the model or
are you running with like the other
ones? There's one second. Bunch of Brook
model.
He's going to go. He doesn't He doesn't
remember. He just he just bought a
couple of shoes and whichever ones
didn't hurt his feet he
used I'm I'm I use a Bondi Hoka Bondi
eights. They're not really running, but
yeah, I mean, they are technically PAS
are running. I I have uh I used to I
tried the Brooks um I tried one of the
Brooks. Um and I didn't really like it.
Yeah, I felt the toe box is too narrow.
So now I have Alt, if you know what
those are. Uh I got w I got wide wide.
Their body wide stretching right now.
Yeah. No, that's you. It's actually It's
actually a really good idea to
incorporate into your daily routine.
Yeah. Not just having it in one kind of
space where you're pushing yourself.
Yeah. Well, it's just it's it's easier
if you integrate it uh to to make sure
it gets done.
Yeah. Well, I I haven't gotten my
training done in a long time, so I get
that. I've been slacking as well.
I'll get it today. Today I'll hit
um a dice. Adrenalines.
Nice. Adrenalines.
Okay. Here in just just a bit. Let me
see. Brooks,
I believe so. Yeah. Yeah. I see.
Uh, do you have like the more of like
the the the bottom that's more like
spiked or Well, I mean they're No, they
look the same. I got a couple different
pairs.
Yeah, you don't slip with those like in
the trails. Not at all. Nice. Yeah. I
don't know. I I got a pair of Hokas and
hated them and I got these and these
were great.
Mhm.
I put uh 1,500 miles last year. I'm the
I'm not doing that again this year. I'm
probably going to try to hit like 750ish
this year.
Yeah, that's still a lot, dude.
Yeah. Well, I mean, like I don't know.
Maybe I will. We'll see. For now, I'm
just trying to get my weight back on and
get my muscle and strength back. Mhm. Um
I lost 18 pounds in January, so I'm
trying to put that all back on.
You do mostly compound lifts or Yeah. Um
mostly.
Yeah.
I don't know. I
did uh what I do like three sets of push
presses today and then I've just been
doing light like light bench sets of 15
to 20 just every time I get up. Aside
from that.
Yeah. Um, do you do any like calisthenic
stuffs or like pull-ups? Uh, I do some
pull-ups. That's about it. Mhm. Have you
tried weighted pull-ups? Uh, when I did
weighted pull-ups, my best was a two
plate weighted for one. So, 245s. Yeah.
That's That's insane. Yeah. But now, you
know, I really like this thing. I don't
know if I'll be able to hit it having
just benched, but this thing in the
background, this is great. The the
stepping thing, the
step. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
saw that. Was like
sick. Yeah. Oh, yeah. It's like it's
like it's it's like a salmon ladder, but
not like like a static salmon ladder.
Yeah. Damn. Oh, is he going all the way
up? Uh, no, he
Well, that thing's a lot of fun. Yeah. I
mean, that that's good if you have the
budget for it. I'm running on budget.
So, what I do is I do like uh Do you
know what front levers are? Yeah. I
don't do that type of calisthenics
stuff, but I know those. Yeah, I do that
and then I basically have all I need for
calisthenics is a dip bars, a uh like a
chair and um like a pull-up bar with a
weighted vest and that's all I need cuz
then again I can just progressively
overload. I mean technically all I need
is like just a base rack and a bench
with a bar but uh you know it's more fun
to have it's more fun when you have a
bunch of stuff. Yeah. Yeah. You you have
your training you have your literally
your uh train environment training
facility not written in C though not
written in C maybe I am though I don't
know
yeah maybe
so uh we got your set oh
I just did so bet this is the
new this you'll find this interesting
for
So this is what it currently looks like.
The puffer lib folder, the pi files in
it. Interesting.
Very interesting. So
it's 3.3k total. Way fewer files. A lot
of stuff I moved all the little shitty
files I moved into just pufferlib.py.
Okay. Oh, yeah. That's a new one. Yeah.
And then clean pufferell is going to go
in here now. So then that'll bring us to
under 5k for the entire puffer python.
Like all the puffer python. So it's all
it's all going to be in the puffer lib
folder. Puffer lib. Puffer lib. Oh, I I
think I already showed you that I merged
the demo file with clean puffl.
Uh no. Oh, so this is this is less than
a thousand lines of actual code now. And
it has both. That's wild. You were you
were Oh, you know what? No, I watched
you editing it. I didn't I didn't look
on the bottom to see what file you were
in, though. I just assumed you were in
demo. Yeah. No, this is everything now.
So, this is like there a couple bugs,
but it's like it's super condensed. And
uh I mean, it's literally we're getting
Well, except it's not
golfed. It's not golfed at all. That's
uh extreme extreme intensity because
both of those files were kind of
daunting. Yeah.
So the hope is this should just make it
way easier now for people and like it's
just a much thinner stack as well.
Um I think that honestly if I tried
really hard I could probably cut another
like 700 lines out of this thing but it
would take so much time. I'm gonna
settle for cutting, you know, another
couple hundred out and we'll call it
there.
So, I mean, I think it looks great.
Everything's going in in there
basically.
Uh, something like that, Jason. Is in
fact
planned. Something like that is in fact
planned.
But you don't like the the paint thing?
I think it's pretty good.
There is actually a plan to have
a a big TV I can point to camera
at. All right. So, we got boys nicely.
Yeah. Uh, what are we doing here? The
only other thing I really want to get
done today, I got like 20
minutes. I don't know what the heck is
wrong
with our
probability
function. I would have sworn that I'd
fixed it with the other thing, but it
didn't work.
When's the release, Joseph? As soon as I
damn will finish it.
All right, I will get get back to doing
that. Uh, it's tricky to get to get
Grock to play Pokemon. Very very tricky
business. Uh, that's why you should have
told Yap and it's like, "Hey, I did I
spot." Yeah. No, I'm constantly spamming
him. He knows he It's not It's not in
line with his It's not in line with his
his persona and it's not in line with
his, you know, funny as hell
engagement.
N is this what happened?
I'm going to go for a walk. So, I'll
catch you guys later.
Linky.
Yeah. What's up? Welcome, man. How's it
going? We are on stream.
Yeah, that that's fine. I'm just living
life. Figured I'd stop by. It's been a
minute. Yeah, man. I've been trying to
I've been working towards this new
release. We've got some stuff going.
How's the uh how's your M going?
Uh well, I kind of haven't been working
on it for a while. I figured I should
probably study some, you know, linear
calculus and all that so I could better
understand things. And then linear
algebra or multivariant calculus, not
linear calculus.
So, probably good to know linear
algebra. No linear algebra. Well, you
only need the calc is not bad at all
because you only need derivative
calculus and you need it to the extent
of like I don't know knowing chain rule
and that's about derivatives. Yeah.
Yeah. Partial. That's all you need. It's
just like a tiny tiny fraction. Uh
linear algebra is bigger but honestly
the thing that's most useful is just
being comfortable with tensor
operations.
Yeah. like you know
matrix multiplication vector kind of
operations. Yeah, there are a handful of
tricks that are like useful to know. Oh
yeah, thank you for the advertising
there. Bet folks watching, please do
star the puffer. He eats stars. It's all
open source. Helps us out for free.
Puffer.ai. Star the puffer. This is
rounded to 2K now. I'm hoping that we
get to actual rounded. What's the actual
number? It
is 199. 1.8. We're seven off of actual
2000. Wow. That's cool. Nice.
That's cool.
Yeah. We should uh do a puffer
celebration once we get to 2K. I don't
know how I like I don't know what I can
possibly do. I'm already like on here
streaming constantly. Yeah, just just
hit a like a bench. I don't know, like a
bench set when we reach 2K. Have you
not? I've been doing that in the
background. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
don't know. Like uh I like I can't even
do an impressive bench set at this
moment. I had a 1k total before
pneumonia. Um you could do a uh you
could do a like match rep to your
uh your star count.
Oh my. Yeah, dude. Do like a full stream
where you're trying to reach 2K.
Not
just that's how you know you know what
Rabdo is cuz that's how you get You want
Rabdo cuz that's how you get Rabdo. No,
don't do it only for bench. Do it for
like like bench plus squats plus
pull-ups plus whatever. Do you have any
idea how Okay, I've done like I think
I've done like one star equals one rep.
We're not looking for historical. We're
looking for the the difference between
when you start stream to end stream.
I could do that. I don't know.
Yeah, I just Great idea. Why? Just one
stream where you try to reach 2k reps or
2k stars. One star is one rep. Yeah. Oh,
yeah. Yeah. The different Yeah. Yeah.
You're right. You're right. Maybe I'll
do that when I get all my new gym
equipment.
Yeah. Like for every star during the
stream, you do a rep. Mhm.
So, I see a lot of
enviable terminals. What exactly is that
used for? Dun.
What? So you know the done flag like
reward obs like was it OBS rewards
action done?
Yeah, I think terminal is end episode.
Truncated is end experiment. Uh it's not
quite. So it's terminal is end of
episode. Truncated is you reached the
time limit. You didn't like die or like
beat the level. It's still over.
Yeah. like a
non-criminal is like um the kind of and
it's it's reached its conclusion kind of
thing,
right? It's basically the episode is
over. Yes. And truncated is the episode
specifically episode is like the I don't
know you play the game the agent dies
you like what like whatever wherever
makes sense logically to whatever your
reset condition is. Yeah. Yes. Okay.
Okay. I
don't even really need these to be
honest. Yeah, that's that's what I mean.
Like for boys, is there really an
episode? There's just one. I honestly
don't even think that it matters that
much. Um
I Yeah, you could literally just delete
duns and everything. Well, the thing is
that there are Ms where like there are
Ms that you like you can construct cases
in which the duns matter, but usually
they don't.
This is the last the last thing I want
to fix today which I can't figure out is
why the hell we're getting nans now.
We're only like we're getting nans when
we're getting bad hyperparameters which
is normal but it's not supposed to crash
torch. It's just supposed to make the
loss explode.
Do you have like epsilon for protection?
I always have protection.
So, more about this major release. Is
this going to be a 3.0 branch on your
repo? I think it's going to be
25. It depends how good the baselines
are. If we get ridiculously good
baselines, it'll be 3 0.
If even if it's a 2.5 release, do you
still plan on making that the main
GitHub branch? Absolutely.
Perfect. Um, I'd just love to get my
hands on the new bindings and I just I
don't touch the dev branch if I'm being
honest.
Well, well, dev the thing with that is
like main is always going to be it gets
up to like up to six months behind. My
dev cycles are usually four to six
months. Sometimes it's two to two to six
months, but yeah, it just it kind of
depends.
I mean, you can probably at least I
remember with like the plugin I created,
I had like basically this bot, this
GitHub actions that would um kind of re
like I can choose when to release stuff
and it can create for me like a change
log and everything automatically just
for my commits. So that might be a thing
you want to look at.
What's that? So I there's GitHub. So, if
you're using a specific kind of like
commit format, there's a GitHub actions
bot that can uh like automatically
generate you all like the change log, um
all like the release notes and stuff of
like this is what was fixed, this was
what changed, this is what was added and
stuff. Um it can do that all
automatically and you can kind of decide
when you want to release that and it
does all the version bumping for you and
everything like that.
But that's like if you want to follow
kind of the release cycle of like uh uh
something you do with like uh semantic
versioning. But from what I'm hearing,
you would just want to kind of go by
like feel pretty much. Well, the thing
is it would be 0.1 point 2.3, but then
open AI and everybody kind of screwed up
the whole versioning thing by going in
0.5s or like one increments. But like
now nobody gives a [ __ ] if you release
if I release this as 2.1 nobody cares,
right?
I would argue I think that was more so
the game industry that messed up the
major minor patch versioning.
I don't know. I know a lot of open-
source projects still use that and like
like but that's the thing. Yeah. Like
people don't like the hype is when kind
of a newer like a 1.0 or a 2.0 kind of
gets released.
Yeah. Big number goer essentially. Yeah.
Yeah.
nans into where telling you drop an
epsilon. There is an epsilon. That
doesn't help you when you have a nan.
That's actually fair. I I was You got
NAND on, man.
Oh, wait. Hang on. Is it in the It could
be in the hyper
pram sweeps
Okay. Is it max minus min? Oh, wait.
Hang on. This I think I know what it is.
Damn it.
Linky, we were missing epsilon
protection.
Epsilon strikes again.
We We were in
fact missing the epsilon.
Now, I'm not the most knowledgeable
person, but I'll take a decent shot in
the
Okay, look. I can't be expected to not
ever miss an epsilon. Okay, this is it's
a small indie company.
That's why we're we're here. We got to
make sure, you know, sanity checks
happen.
want to get this thing to not crash for
now.
disappears to run. We will see whether
it is stable or not. In
fact, we will
thing. Why does teams mess with your VIN
theme as well? Sketchy.
You can use like a terminal with a
built-in multiplexers. There's a lot of
them. Yeah, going to get ghost TTY at
some point.
I was going to say you could just verify
that it's on like
uh 256 color, true color or whatever. If
you're using like fancy coloring, you
have to change the color scheme of your
terminal.
this GPC
norm
unlinearize. Oh, I did it right, didn't
I? Here, one
here. Where's Yorm? Ah, why
arm? Very good. We shall
see how this does.
Okay, that is
enabled. We've
got there's probably more training steps
worth of data on this graph than most
PhD students do in their whole
PhDs. Actually, it's way more than that,
come to think of it. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Way
more.
So, is each line in like a different
environment? Each one of these is an
experiment run on neural MMO in which it
played 2,000 years worth of games.
Okay. And some cut short because why?
Because like like what's your
termination condition? I guess it just
wasn't working or some of them crashed
or whatever.
But like yeah, the full ones on these
are 100 billion steps, which I believe
is it 500 bytes
each. So is that
um I think it's 500 terabytes of data
each. Is that correct? 500 gigabytes or
500 terabytes? 500 terabytes.
It's a lot of data.
Yeah. for so you said like you have five
million you know for a single run right
it's a lot of data
yeah and this you can see the
progression where I think the 20
baseline is around 2.5 2.6 six or
something. So you can see the
progression
and uh Y I just want to make sure Y is
the reward and
then X is
the episodes
X is total steps trained
Hopefully maybe maybe with mine we can
once it's done once voids is actually
working we can sweep it and see what
happens. Yeah. Yours is not going to
take a 100red billion steps to train. I
can guarant. Yeah. I know. Of course. Of
course.
But there's so much cool stuff that you
can do with voids cuz like Yeah. I don't
know. It depends how much you want to do
with it. But like one thing that would
be hilarious would just be like to put
it in the on the web page somehow. Not
just like as a thing you click into, but
have the puffers just swim around the
web page. Yeah. As like an idol
animation or something. I don't know. I
mean, do you know it's kind of ripped
off from David Ha.
David Ha. David Ha has this
awesome Does he still have it onto? No.
See, he used to have all these like
multi-agent things. He used to do all
this stuff. Now he does he runs like the
national lab for AI in Japan.
Um he's kind of like their AI celebrity.
Wow. I mean he's But the thing is he's
legitimate. He's not just like he's done
like all sorts of cool work. He's Yeah,
he's not Sam Alman.
Yeah, Alman is Man, it's freaking I wish
it just I wish OpenAI had stayed like
open. It was so freaking awesome in
2019.
Like, it was such a cool place. It's the
best place I've ever worked by a mile. I
love So, did you work on the on the
agents thing where they did the
hideand-seek thing? Cuz that was sick.
So, funny thing about that, uh, if
they'd actually if they'd given me a
full-time offer, I would have. I told
them exactly what was going to go wrong
with that project, and lo and behold, a
year later, it went wrong in exactly the
way I told them.
Wow. It's it's it's such a cool project
though because the there were some
emergent like um papa that were just
mindblowing right and that worked and
that I and that I told them would work.
This stuff is all the appendix like the
whole appendix of that paper is about
transfer learning. I told them it
wouldn't work. I told them why it
wouldn't work and lo and behold it
mostly didn't work.
Yeah. Um but emergent tool use is a fun
is a is a very cool project. Now the
thing is if I had done it in puffer lib
like the thing is we could actually
probably we could probably reproduce
like pretty well that result uh on like
one to eight GPUs.
Do you think puffer will uh at some
point get uh 3DS like we'll we have
3DMs. We'll expand to three Oh, we do
already. Yeah, we have 3Ds.
I mean, don't we have a I could I'm
probably going to butcher this
pronunciation, but Majoku, Majuko,
whatever it is. Uh, but first party.
Uh, I see. So, we have this Spencer made
this. Oh, this is a random agent and the
animations like glitch sometimes, but
yeah, this is a 3D puzzler and right I
mean the thing is like the distinction
the 3D 2D distinction doesn't actually
matter all that much like you know
Runescape is technically 2D.
Yeah. I mean sure, right? Like it's just
rendered 3D like the uh the emergent
tool use paper except for the ramps. The
only thing that makes it not three like
not 2D is the ramps.
Right. Yeah.
And like literally like you could have
probably modeled it like with 2D and
just have the ramps like bridge you over
like it the fact that it's 3D barely
does anything
right. I mean yeah doesn't do much but
like anyway it's like it's
depict fancy physics right? It's like
the fancy physics is the thing that
matters and is annoying. Yeah.
Yeah. And we've also got Where's Do we
have Impulse Wars bound correctly?
Oh, is I can only take credit for
helping with the front end of this.
Oh, it I guess it doesn't render. That's
shitty. Oh, wait.
Are you evaling?
Yeah, you are.
Uh it shouldn't be.
Render is true. Okay.
Is it just render then?
I don't know why he did this like this.
It's kind of silly. No, it's just it's
it's improperly named.
All right. Well, we'll have to fix it.
Render impulse wars is really cool. Uh,
we got to get that thing working
nicely. Do our runs
work? This one crashed.
I suspect the maze
one maze is
still
right. Well, hopefully that works. I am
going to go get dinner. I've got a call
to take. I've got a few things to do.
And yeah, we will see. I think I
probably will come back later in the
evening for some dev. I don't know.
I'm
uh I actually I normally like to keep my
days longer than eight hours and I feel
like good and productive for at least
10. But when I'm doing freaking like
this type of shitty pre-release work,
it's like it's more of a marathon where
it's like you just got to be productive
over two weeks of like doing with all
this annoying stuff because like the
work just isn't interesting. Um it just
it's always this way for release. Like
the least productive times for me are
always pre-release and then the worst is
writing a paper which thankfully I don't
have to do anymore. Um hope hopefully
I'll can get boys ready in a good state
before like you're already releasing so
we can get we can push it with this
release. We got a whole bunch of M that
we're waiting on as well like impulse
war's got to be finished. GPU drives got
to be finished.
Um there's there was another one as
well, right? What's the other big one?
Um the one uh the the self-driving one.
Yeah, that's GPU drive. I think those
are the two big ones we're waiting on.
Anyways, um for the folks watching at
the moment, thanks for dropping by. Uh
all my stuff's free and open source.
Puffer.ai with some fun demos here. If
you want to help me out for free, just
star the repo. Almost at 2K proper
stars, not rounded. If you want to get
involved with development, join the
Discords,
discord.gg/puffer. Uh, most of our top
contributors came in with zero RL
experience. So, it's a great place to
learn as well. And if you'd like more RL
content, you can follow me on X. Check
out the blog, which is also on X. Has
stuff for new people to RL, but also
some cutting edge RL stuff and some
discussion there as well. Oh, thank you.